when you think about the idea of black
lives matter they do matter and the
reality is that me as a black person
um you know people are getting murdered
on the street people are getting shot
down and
and the understanding that you know it's
not like that for every other race
like that
in particular
um
you know for the black community and
you know i think about you know my you
know my stepson i think about you know
my daughter i think about
i think about our new baby boy on the
way and uh
[Music]
it's uh it's kind of staggering it's
it's staggering to watch
these things happen right in front of
our faces
and uh so i i have a heavy heart right
now and uh and i think uh you know like
i said i don't have all the right
answers or anything and to be honest
with that i don't even want to talk
about football right now um you know
that's that's the thing that i don't
even know what that looks like down the
road or anything else and i think that
none of that matters i can't compare
football to
to life and
what what you know black community is
going through right now and
um
you know what i do what i what i think
is right i think that people should have
the ability to peacefully protest and be
able to you know express
you know their frustration their hurt
and their pain
[Music]
russell wilson powerful emotional
comments yesterday
regarding the current situation he
doesn't want to talk about football we
don't either russell there's no football
to talk about especially at a time like
this with what is happening in the
country in this moment that is upon us
will there be equality and justice for
all or will there not be once and for
all justice for all is what we need and
uh and chris you know i i i don't want
to psychoanalyze russell wilson here
but i think he is shaken to his core by
this as well because when you're an nfl
quarterback and you're spending
52 weeks of the year honing your craft
playing the game working out he lives a
life of privilege that he has earned
through his athletic ability
but i i i feel like in a roundabout way
that he is an african-american a man
wasn't
wasn't as sensitive to what was going on
beyond his bubble
and i think that that has shaken him and
i think that is part of what we saw come
through from him yesterday
yeah i think that's right and you don't
listen and it's not like russell wilson
being insensitive or anything like that
this is just a guy that's highly
motivated highly focused on his job
which yeah to a degree puts him in that
bubble because all he's worried about is
being a better quarterback being the
leader of the seattle seahawks team
offense and and playing football at a
really high level
but you know i think no matter how
focused you are on that task or job
right now
it's yeah it's hard not to think about
the issues we got in this country let
alone we know we got
players in the league who are out there
protesting and have family members that
are out there protesting and they're in
the fight and putting themselves in
danger so it hits home and of course so
many of these players have seen a lot of
these bad incidents happen
right in front of their eyes as their
lives played out growing up
so russell wilson extremely smart guy uh
i think yeah he is kind of understanding
where we are and you know the other
thing that just comes out to me about
russell wilson there and where i think
it probably hits home more for a guy
like that right now is when you start
having young kids you start to think
about what's america going to look like
in the future what's this world going to
look like in the future you know that's
why i'm passionate about this subject
and the environment and things like that
because you think about your kids and
you want them to be in a a better world
than you're in right now so uh russell
wilson is well said by him he's
extremely smart and he's one of those
guys that can
certainly force a lot of change in this
country and make people rethink their
positions
and that fear of what the future will be
for our children i think is such a great
motivator and
if you
if you are the parent of an
african-american child it is a real
concern what kind of life will they have
when will they be in the worst possible
place at the worst possible time and
encounter a police officer whose idea of
the justice system is i am judge jury
and executioner and the punishment will
be meted out within the next eight
minutes and 46 seconds it's
incomprehensible that people have to
carry those fears around and the hope is
we are at a point where change will come
where the system will indeed finally get
to the point where this is a nation of
equity and justice for every man woman
and shop
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports